co-host of intentional talk 5 p.m. live
from Fenway Park leading up to the Red
Sox Astros game on MLB Network at 7:00
Eastern Time are you in Boston right now
coming I'm in Boston right now I'm
looking at this gray skies I'm looking
at some slight Lane it's supposed to
stop here in the next probably hours so
the game will be not in jeopardy but
she's on the field on my beanie what is
it like for you to walk the streets of
Boston Matt what's that like
walk me through you know what it's truly
like we get out last night by the way
Chris roses hello right back out of
Richie I said well love it
and so we we got out like like we just
got a car service get to the hotel it's
about 11 o'clock I think the restaurant
closed and the Bellman's like hey good
to have you back how you doing and I'm
not a recognizable face like I'm not 6
foot 11 and a half you know with the
mullet that you know it's like family
like they left it they let the
restaurant remain open we got a chance
to quit get our room keys and go down
and have two seats right there and we
order some clam chowder and lobster
bisque and watch the rest of his
basketball game yeah because we were
talking about this off the top of the
show Kevin with the Boston Bruins now in
the Stanley Cup final and and and how it
started obviously with Brady beating the
Rams in that Super Bowl in New Orleans
and then the Red Sox followed it up by
breaking the curse with you and the rest
of the team and now it how many how many
final four appearances in sports Chris
did you say since 28 28 now Kevin I mean
but it wasn't that way when you were
trying to break the curse was it yeah
well it wasn't that way the Patriots had
one I think maybe three out of four in
that and a toe three 2:05 time right so
they kind of just got the map Red Sox
hadn't won anything yet in a six years
we win and also the Celtics got rid of
the Bruins and then it became like now
the question would ask is Boston spoiled
okay they said you in the Red Sox last
year World Series champions you had the
Patriots doing their thing with Brady
and then you got the Bruins in the
finals like the Celtics they play as
good as they should overlook cuz I
thought that team had a chance to win
the title starting the season
you know and they just they never kind
of gone track in the postseason but are
they spoiled is the question well I mean
my Masshole across the way here in Chris
Brockman and you you just bristled at
that question you are spoiled why would
you even bristle with the question that
my largest a spoiled spoiled how how you
bitching and moaning about years of
misery the Patriots were terrible
forever yeah
the answer is B the answer is yes of
course you're spoiled in Boston you'll
be kidding me you gotta love it if
you're a Boston fan you're from Boston
there's no place no city like it right
now because it's truly amazing I mean
what Tom Brady's done over his career
and the Red Sox have won 1 for 7 13 18
this four World Series in that span and
then the Berlin's man they just don't
they don't stop it's crazy all right
well the Red Sox seem to have righted
the ship this year right I mean are they
on the street now the best you can tell
now Kevin is badly played right up to
this point to last week let's say you
know everybody else talk about the
hangover effect and I don't know what
the answer to that is but we salt with
the Cubs in 17 we saw it with the Astros
and 18 with all the Red Sox now the
first five weeks of the season I think
we were magnifying every every Chris
Sale sale start whether we was throwing
91 or 88 or 97 you know in April but I
think right now you look at this club
they're a good ballclub period in a
story they're a good ballclub as it
keeps up here in the East Coast family
parts gonna get real small and Mookie
Betts is going to hit about 340 the next
second half it's just the way it is been
attendee and Xander and you know you got
Devers over there no one's even talking
about leading the league in hitting so
Joby this group that good sales throwing
the ball well obviously struck out 17 is
last start 17 we all want him to go back
out but that's not the way it goes these
days everything is magnified by a number
of good news and there you have well you
got the two last two World Series
champions going at it tonight obviously
in Fenway Park and the Astro is appear
to be just as good as ever man I mean
they're 14 over right now best record in
Major League Baseball as you and I
are conversing what what are there holes
do they have any best you can tell Kevin
they really don't their bullpens lie out
Presley's been unbelievable I think he's
got 38 or 39 scoreless innings to to
bridge the gap to the seventh inning
game they play do they got a great
starting pitching Gerrit Cole strikes
out early buddy Justin Verlander seems
like a Tom Brady of baseball
he's not gonna age offensively they're
unbelievable Alex Bregman has this team
just with a swagger bottom so I just
need George Springer who's a better
leadoff hitter or threat at the top of
the lineup the Jerry Springer he sits up
there you know batter number one you can
put your dead center anytime you have
that's like the old Ricky Henderson days
right you just like you got power up the
top speed athleticism Michael Brantley
was a great addition they're the best
team out there you know they're the best
team period and what's disappointing is
that division how many games are they
win the division by is gonna be 15 no
Seattle and angels and Texas and Oakland
like that's the disappointing you know
aspect about that because no one's gonna
contend with them well I mean Seattle
started like a house of fire and then
obviously fell off and the Angels fell
off and now that they're there circling
around 500 right now and then obviously
with trout in Otani now back and hitting
the baseball you obviously yeah I mean
I'm just trying to put some sort of
sunny scene on the AL West AL central I
mean other twins the biggest surprise in
baseball this year I don't know the
biggest surprise I look at that division
once again Casey wasn't gonna be good
Detroit's not gonna be good the White
Sox are still waiting for every prospect
in the world would be well they're not
they're not ready to be the Indians or
head scratchers right there try and
trade Trevor Bauer they're trying trade
Corey Kluber they're trying on the
beginning thing I'm like you don't
realize how fortunate you are to have a
chance to win at the division again so
it's almost like they push their hands
crombel as well just go through the
motions and think we're gonna win this
division as Minnesota was adding Nellie
Cruz and Crone and making this lineup
powerful they score runs they hit home
runs
Eddie Rosario is unbelievable I think
most underrated player in the big
leagues we don't talk enough about him
their starting staff now is makes you
scratch your head go do they have enough
to maintain and it asked that question
in this division I'd say yes I'll enrich
I think there's enough what they need to
do but they'll add a little bit I think
Rocco Baldelli their managers done a
great job and the twins organization has
always done well with small market money
and so I don't think there are any
surprise I think that the Indians need
to get combo check looking at mere sake
Kevin Millar here on MLB Network on the
Rich Eisen show can I give you an
under-the-radar surprise team totally
under the radar surprised team yes how
about the Yankees being 10 over 500 with
everybody hurt pretty much 100 percent
if the season ended today Aaron Boone's
player you I remember the year period
that star Phil Nevin third-base coach
he's got low hips he's been working out
looks good in his arms area but I'm
gonna tell you honest to god they've
done a great job you haven't heard them
complain one time they had 13 guys on a
deal end of April when we were there
doing the show that wasn't bird just
went on that day I'm like 13 think about
it and they've had just a nothing but a
double a triple eight you know team
they've been stealing fielding and then
you look at her mom coming in and and
going for his eighth win the other day
as a starting pitcher like they lose
Soriano their ace there's not a whole
lot of teams have had worse luck than
them and ten games over 526 and 16 like
you said have the game out behind the
Rays who have been playing good all year
and that just tell you how good the
Yankees are so so if I had to give you a
choice and I'm doing that because it's
sports talk radio
you could build a team around Yelich or
Bell in here who do you do what do you
you could choose only one yell at your
Bellinger have an absolutely tremendous
question thank you sir and you're
probably I'm right in a shot here okay
Bellinger's a check younger right oh I
would I would I would go with Bellinger
because I could play him anywhere on the
diamond almost it almost feels like I
can play him a shortstop he probably my
best shortstop he placed first he plays
every outfield position I think he plays
it at a high level I think he's going to
slow the game down as he goes Chris and
yells one of my favorite though I'm
that's a great question I would go with
the age younger ballinger but didier
it's football
you ain't going wrong well I mean here
we are Kevin he's he's four years
younger than Yelich and we're we're just
ordering about eight days nine days away
from 10 days sorry from from Memorial
Day that's the the unofficial quarter
post pole position of the season kids
over 400 I mean this day and age were
shifting and we're we're analyzing as
analytics this and you're seeing 18
different pictures in the game because
this guy throws smoke this guy does this
this guy does that 400 that's insane
what he is doing right now insane
Bellingen and with that violent swing
and you just look at him I love like I
love what he said before in spring
training
I'm not platooning I'm gonna play every
day because this team's a better team
when I'm in the lineup every day because
the batter's have like 37 different
lines if the right is it lefties
Bissonnette and sometimes you saw him
you know last last year he played a lot
of games but I think he started 100 and
whatever it was 35 but he wants play
every night he was player yet he doesn't
care lefty righty and I love that about
him that was going into camp sir he's
kind of like oh okay really well guess
what I'm hitting 400 also in the first
six weeks of the season but I love
players that believe in themselves you
know and a better question is rich when
you sit here talking about you know a
Bollinger Yelich you sit back and you
know we're this conversation last week
that intentional talk like where's Bryce
Harper fit in those categorise talks you
know you got you got Mike Trout you got
Bellinger you got Arenado you got Rondo
cunha jr. in Atlanta you're the kid Soto
and in BC you know it's 21 but you start
asking who would you start your team
with you know Bryce you know he's
probably in the top plan maybe but
there's some players now let me alex is
really kind of like middle he's an MVP
they clap him like he's not that good
I'm thinking this dude's got 18 home
runs he was a most valuable player last
year you better start locking in on
Chris and yellow this is a good ball
player this is a fake it's amazing I
mean he leads the league in homers at 18
but Bellinger leads an average and RBI
it's been it's been a it's been a lot of
fun so far before I let you go Kevin
Millar again an intentional talk you and
Chris Rose 5:00 Eastern Time from Fenway
before tonight's Astros Red Sox series
at 7:00 Eastern on MLB Network is it
true you were at Bethpage block
yesterday is that a fact Kevin a champ
Wednesday I was once I was there Ritchie
Wednesday what beautiful helicopter ride
over landed on there on the fairway in
the red course I believe it was
absolutely awesome watched them on the
driving range I love watching drills
like when you go to the advances it's
awesome but I got to kind of follow your
head bobbing you're throwing a few
elbows it's like sitting in the middle
seat on Southwest like you're gonna you
know you gotta throw some elbows trying
to get that arm sure but practice round
days unbelievable cuz I could like what
are they working on what's there putty
girls what sir it was awesome it was
beautiful blue skies and flew back to
network and had a chance to I felt like
that was a last thousand redbridge the
famous robin Leach well I mean they just
put a photograph from at came a la 15 on
the screen is that Faldo you and Founder
i did some rapid fires you know that's
been Mike's right who's the one golfer
that would that you find in the 19th the
19th hole after a match or who's the one
that talks in most trash a lot of
answers were filled Mickelson he talks
the most trash he's obviously the ones
ventilation bell on the line that's fun
hey it was funny because that was next
answer also the guide Pats most dragon
classes uh is uh was was lefty and then
he also said Stenson was funny
extensions you really funny and on some
smack got a great and then there's
another photograph if he could put it up
on the screen as well when you arrived
in Boston is that uh the famed at Jack
and Coke as well that was a waiting for
you upon arrival so I got in about 1209
you know I am late night yes I walk in
the room and it's just hello mr. Kevin
Millar and there was two coca-cola
bottles by the way if he who doesn't
love drinking Coca that a bottle and a
little thing of philosophy of Jack
Daniels and I'm like hey they'll never
go away that's why I love me some Boston
a couple shots and a sweep of the
Yankees four straight your forever love
you
and which at 1:16 Eastern time the
following afternoon is still filled
which one of those bottles still filled
Kevin okay but i'm mateus at 6:01 when
intentional talks over ya might lose a
little bit of the fingers it'll be a
couple fingers shy okay very good Kevin
say hi to Chris love our chats always
let's chat again soon it's Kevin Millar
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app